da wir haben schon einmal getroffen weiß
noch wo ja in münchen ich weiß nur dass
hat der olympique im frühstücksraum und
weißt du doch mit welchem sagte die
verabschiedeten ich gehe jetzt den
führer schneiden
das ist gut dass wir mal was in singen
kommen habe ich wirklich den finger
geschnitten
ja das war vorher geschneidert
geschnitten habe ich ihn ja ja das hat
uns verbunden
das hat uns verbunden bis heute wie wir
sehen und jetzt haben uns lange jahre
nicht gesehen und jetzt kommst du hier
nach deiner hauptprobe gutes gefühl
nein das ist ob das ein gutes zeichen
für irgendeine ich bin panisch aufgrund
seiner schieren bund aus kannst du es
mal zeigen ja habt ihr habt ihr die zeit
als es dauert bis ein viertel auf
gemacht habe und alles nein es geht es
ist wirklich es ist ein eigenartiger
prozess ich finde es so ein freier fall
im vergleich zu meiner arbeit die ich
sonst mache das sich wirklich respekt
vor haben so hast du die erwartung an
das zürcher publikum flippte die aus der
emotionale inhalte oder super emotional
also das ist wirklich also ich glaube
die stehen in der regel schon im zweiten
satz auf verlassen das theater das ist
ganz schwierig es ja sager zürich ist
man meinen dass ein so was das heim der
alten erwarte ich schon dass fähige tanz
der in aufführung das stück an der
ersten leseprobe komplett fertig
ich hab gestern nacht noch geschrieben
bis 31 und wie reagieren die
schauspieler sind es gewohnt noch sind
sie cool also ich weiss nicht glaube es
wird wahrscheinlich dann also die
toleranz wird wahrscheinlich abnehmen
die dichter wir an den
aufführungsterminen kommen ja ich glaube
dass die gegeben aber die kriegen jetzt
sie haben heute einen völlig neuen
dritten abbekommen denn ich gestern nach
geschrieben ob deswegen bin ich also
tasten das war bei brecht und
shakespeare genau so haben sie mir
selber gesagt ich bin ein bisschen älter
als du
wir sind das sind wir ja definitiv aber
bei mir sieht man es nicht weil ich
natürlich öffentlicher bisher bisher in
der gemütlichkeit deiner dank seines
lebens und ich bin gerade in der
anspannung bei dir geht's richtig los
ist die liebe zum theater jetzt noch mal
neu ins land
ja ja also ich find es eine völlig
andere welt und es ist auch eine ganz
andere art von regie führen
ja das ist so eine es ist so ein hohes
adrenalin was auf der bühne sein muss
dass es irgendwie zündet auch weil das
stück auch eigentlich böse ist weil es
ohne sonne so eine schärfe haben muss
bei in diesem stück da brennen die hat
die schweiz auch auf eine art und das
ist dann irgendwo wichtig dass die
schauspieler das spüren dürfen nicht
bequem sein aber wenn ich jetzt höre
dass meine geliebte schweiz brennt wird
sie dann gelöscht
ja ja ja keine sorge sie klingt nun also
ich kann
nein das ist auch ein angenehmes es
riecht lecker uns werden würstchen
gegrillt alles gut alles gut
heute teuer